- All right.
Welcome, everyone. Welcome to NET217.
Hope you're having a
fine re:Invent so far.
Hope you caught the keynote this morning.
My name is Adhish Bhobe. I'm
a product manager with AWS.
I have with me, Matt Engskow.
He's a principal engineer
and we are both from the
Amazon Route 53 team.
We are gonna talk about a new launch
that we just released a couple
of days back called Amazon
Route 53 Global Resolver.
But before we begin, just a
quick show of hands in the room.
How many of you are network
administrators who dabble
with DNS security?
I see quite a few hands raised. Great.
Well, you're in the right
session because we are gonna talk
about how you can achieve secure
and also anycast DNS
resolution for your clients
with Global Resolver.
So this is what we're
gonna talk about today.
We're gonna talk about what
are some of the key challenges
that got us here,
what are some of the things
that we heard from you,
our customers that led us
to building Global Resolver.
We are gonna talk about why
you should use Global Resolver
and what are some of the key benefits
that you're gaining
from using the service.
Then I'm gonna turn it over
to Matt who's gonna walk you
through how you can get started
and how you can use this
service in optimal fashion.
There's also going to be a cool demo,
so stick around for that.
We are also gonna have a case study
where we are gonna talk about
how Just Walk Out stores
uses Global Resolver
and how they plan to scale
it across all of the stores.
For those of you who don't know,
Just Walk Out stores is a
technology built by Amazon
for all of its stores,
including Amazon Go and
Amazon Fresh that allows
for cashless and
touchless user experience.
And then I'm gonna end it by talking about
where you can use this service
and which regions it's available,
and also give you a
glimpse about the pricing.
So at the outset,
I wanna talk about the three
key challenges that we heard
from our customers that led us
to building Global Resolver.
First was split-DNS management.
What we heard from our customers
was they were maintaining
forwarding rules for
different customer locations,
for different data centers,
for different branch offices,
and even for the remote clients,
especially to allow split
DNS between private domains
and for public domains on the internet.
In case of AWS specifically,
this meant doing split-DNS management
for private hosted zones,
which is nothing but a container
of domains and subdomains
that you can use for your
private domains hosted
on Amazon VPCs and also to split traffic
to an internet domains
for internet applications.
At the same time,
there were requirements
to have different DNS resolution views
for different sets of clients,
and this added a lot of operational pain
for a lot of our customers
who had to maintain these
and make sure that those are consistent
across all of their locations.
What we also heard from our
customers was the ability
to prevent DNS exfiltration.
DNS exfiltration is a
mechanism that's used
by attackers today to
exfiltrate data over DNS,
and this is a key requirement
for a lot of our customers
who today are using appliances on premises
or setting up their own custom rules
to ensure that clients are not
talking or resolving traffic
to any malicious domains on the internet.
At the same time,
there are requirements
to meet compliance needs
and audit needs to have all of
the logs in a single location
for easy auditing and compliance.
Now let's take this setup
of split-DNS management
and also maintenance of all of your rules
across multiple regions and
multiple customer locations.
This can get very tedious
and it can get very
cumbersome for your teams,
especially when you have
to replicate the same rules
across multiple different locations,
ensure that they're
consistent, up to date,
and that all your clients
are resolving the same set
of domain rules or domains
that you want them to.
At the same time,
ensuring failover between all
of these regions was
another key requirement
that we heard from our customers,
especially for continued DNS resolution.
You may have clients or
you may have applications
that need high availability
DNS resolution resilience
at all times.
And so with that,
we are launching Amazon
Route 53 Global Resolver.
This is available in preview
today for you to use.
Global Resolver is an anycast DNS resolver
that provides you a way
to resolve both private
domains hosted on AWS
as well as public domains
hosted anywhere on the internet.
At the same time,
it allows you to filter traffic
to any malicious domains,
encrypt traffic in transit,
and also log all your queries
across all your locations
in a single region in a
single place of your choice,
making it easy for you
to access those logs.
Global Resolver is optimized for latency,
so it'll always route your traffic
to the closest available
region that you pick.
It's also optimized for resilience,
so in case your clients are not able
to reach a specific region,
it'll automatically failover
to the next available region.
And it's also built for
data residency needs.
We'll talk all about this in
the next couple of slides,
but I want to give you a
glimpse of how it all looks
when it comes together.
Here, you can see
that you may have multiple
corporate data centers,
you may have remote locations,
you may have branch offices.
With Global Resolver now,
they can all point that
traffic to a single anycast IP
without you having to maintain
separate forwarding rules
in every location.
Global Resolver will be
available in the regions
that you pick and will be
able to process your queries
for both private hosted zones
as well as any queries going
out with the internet based
on the filtering rules that you set.
Next, I wanna talk about what
are some of the key reasons
why you should be using Global Resolver.
And this goes back to the challenges
that we just talked about.
With Global Resolver,
you can achieve split-DNS management.
You can resolve both public domains
as well as private hosted
zones from anywhere
from all your customer
locations, wherever they are.
This provides you an easy way
to quickly resolve all your traffic
and simplify all your rule management
across all your customer
locations without you having
to manage forwarding rules
in every single location.
It's internet reachable.
Global Resolver anycast
IPs are internet reachable
so you can reach them over anywhere
from all your authenticated clients.
Which brings me to the next slide.
Global Resolver is not open DNS resolver.
This is only accessible by clients
that you authenticate to
use with Global Resolver,
and there are two ways
that you can authenticate your clients.
One is using IPs.
These are IPs that are
associated with your clients,
maybe your on-premise destinations
or your branch offices
or even your remote clients.
You may also have clients
that may have dynamic IPs
or the IPS may change over
time, and in that situation,
we recommend that you
use access token secrets
that we will wind down
and that you can deploy in your clients.
These will be more permanent
so that even if your clients
are roaming or changing IPs,
they will stay or, and
authenticate with Global Resolver.
Once they're authenticated,
all queries from your clients
will be processed based
on the rules that you'll create.
I wanna talk about another
key notable feature
of Global Resolver, which
is the ability for you
to have more flexibility in
how you group your clients
and your locations.
So you may have different
DNS resolution requirements
for different sets of clients.
For example, for your roaming clients,
you may want to have DNS filtering rules.
You may also want to have the ability
for them to resolve private hosted zones.
You can create a separate
DNS resolution view,
which is a logical grouping
of all your clients,
identify access tokens or IP groups,
and then ensure that any traffic coming
from those clients is treated based
on the rules that you create.
You may also have a different DNS view
for different sets of clients.
So with DNS views used
with Global Resolver,
this gives you that easy,
flexible way of managing all your clients
across different locations
without you having to
create different rules
for each of them and managing them.
Let's talk about how we
can improve DNS security
with Global Resolver.
You will have access to multiple
managed domain categories.
These are pre-configured
categories that are classified
by both the type of DNS threats,
which could be malware, command
and control, spam, phishing,
or even based on the type of
web content that domain hosts.
You can choose to block, alert,
or even allow some of these depending
on your requirements of your clients.
These are pre-configured, so
there's no management from you.
They're automatically updated
and even as you wind down the
rules to different clients,
the (coughs) automatic updates
are automatically moved
and propagated to all
your rules and clients.
I also wanna talk about a
key aspect of DNS protection,
which is how you can improve DNS security
for advanced DNS threats.
There are two specific DNS
threats I wanna talk about.
One is DNS tunneling,
which is a way where an attacker can set
up a DNS tunnel using a malware
that's already pre-propagated
to the client's device
and that malware is sending
malicious DNS queries
to the command and control server.
Using a pattern of request and response,
the DNS tunnel that is
established allows the attacker
to then exfiltrate data
over this DNS request
from the client.
Another DNS advanced threat that we hear
from customers is domain
generation algorithms,
also known as DGAs.
This is where an attacker
can create multiple domains,
multiple bad domains, which
could be in hundreds, thousands,
sometimes even in millions
with the objective of evading
detection so that over time,
even if threat intelligence
feeds are able to catch these,
the attackers moved to
the next possible domain
and carrying out their attack.
Again with Global Resolver,
you can create DNS rules for
these advanced DNS threats.
This look at anomalies in your DNS query,
such as length, the type of query,
query name to make a
probabilistic determination
of whether the query's associated
with DNS tunneling or DGA.
These rules are also customizable,
so you can set rules, for example,
to block the most highly
probabilistic DNS tunneling
or DGA threat,
or you can set a rule at a low confidence
to only alert on these threats
so that your security
teams can then investigate
and make a determination
of whether to block them.
They're all real time,
so all the monitoring is done real time
and in line for all your queries.
Besides DNS exfiltration,
you can also improve your DNS security
by enhancing privacy of your queries,
and with Global Resolver,
you have the ability to use DoH
or DNS over HTTPS,
or DoT, which is DNS over TLS,
both known DNS protocols to
encrypt traffic in transit
between your client and Global Resolver.
This ensures that any
traffic cannot be sniffed
by an attacker in transit.
And then a key requirement for a lot
of our security operations team
is to have all their logging
for all the queries in a single place,
which is also possible
with Global Resolver,
where you can pick the
region of your choice,
an S3 bucket of your choice
to store all those logs.
All right, so we talked about
simplifying DNS resolution,
we talked about DNS
security access controls.
Now let's talk about
another notable feature
of Global Resolver.
Global Resolver is optimized for latency
and also for region failover.
Queries from your clients
are automatically routed
to the closest available location
that you pick with Global Resolver.
We ask that you pick at least two regions
so that whenever a
region is not accessible
from one of your clients
will automatically failover
to the next available region
so that all your queries
are always answered
with high resiliency.
You also have the flexibility
to use Global Resolver
for your data residency needs.
So for example, you may want
to create a different anycast IP
for a different set of regions
or a country depending
on your security mandates
or organizational mandates.
And based on anycast IPs that you create,
your clients will be directed
to the ones that are mandated
by your organization.
So we talked about the key challenges,
we talked about the key benefits.
Let's talk about the key scenarios
when it makes sense for
you to use Global Resolver,
and there are three of them.
First, Global Resolver is
most optimal when you want
to have consistent DNS resolution
across multiple locations.
So you may have multiple data centers,
you may have multiple branch offices,
you may have remote clients
distributed across the world.
If you wanna have
consistent DNS resolution
and security for all of them,
Global Resolver will
provide you necessary rules
and the flexibility to use
them without you having
to spend the time to
create your own rules.
You may also have disconnected sites.
For example, you may have clients
that are directly accessing the internet
that may not be under the
purview of your security teams
or networking teams.
Again, bringing them
under a single anycast IP
with the rules that your team creates,
they're always bound to
resolve to the same domains
that your team has set
without them having to egress
to any TNS location that
is outside the bounds.
And lastly, you may have
critical clients or applications
that need DNS resolution at all times.
With Global Resolver,
you have the ability to easily failover
between different regions
without you having
to manage those failover options yourself.
All right, I've talked about
Global Resolver so far.
I wanna switch topics a little bit.
I wanna ask everyone in the room,
how many of you are familiar
with Route 53 Resolver today?
A lot of you. Yeah.
So as you all know,
Amazon Route 53 Resolver,
this is the default resolver
that comes with all your VPCs,
it allows you to resolve queries
for your private domains,
hosted zones, and any internet domains.
You can also forward
traffic between your VPCs
and your hybrid clients that are connected
to the VPC using Resolver endpoints.
With the Launch Global Resolver,
we are now renaming
Amazon Route 53 Resolver
to be Amazon Route 53 VPC Resolver
for better architectural distinction
and for naming perspective consistency.
I do wanna highlight though
that this changes nothing
in terms of the API operations.
You can continue using Route
53 Resolver the way it is.
There'll be no change over there.
But I do want to highlight
the key differences
and similarities between
these two products
and also talk about when
you should use Global
versus VPC Resolver.
Global Resolver is multi-regional.
It is reachable over the
internet from anywhere
as long as it's authenticated to use.
VPC Resolver, this is the default resolver
for your Amazon VPCs and
for any clients connected
to those VPCs using Resolver endpoints.
Both Global and VPC
Resolvers support encryption,
Global Resolver supports
DoH and DoT protocols.
VPC Resolver supports DoH
protocol today for any traffic
between your VPCs and your hybrid clients.
A key similarity of both
these services is both
of them use DNS firewall.
This is a feature of Route 53
that is in use today
for blocking any traffic
to any malicious domains on the internet.
In terms of positioning,
we expect that you'll use Global Resolver
for any remote networks,
any remote clients,
hybrid networks with a
multi-region footprint.
So you may have multiple regions,
you have multiple locations that you want
without having to spend the time
in creating forwarding
rules for each of those.
VPC Resolver will continue
serving all your clients
within your VPCs and also any
clients that may be connected
to those VPCs using Resolver endpoints.
All right, we have
covered a lot of ground.
I'm gonna turn it over
to my colleague Matt,
who's gonna talk you through
about how you can get started
with this service and
also the best practices.
- Thanks, Adhish. My name's Matt Engskow.
I'm a principal engineer at AWS Route 53,
and I'm incredibly excited to talk to you
about Global Resolver today.
The key takeaways that I want you to have
for this section are, first,
I wanna give you a leg up
such that if you want to use this product,
you can quickly go back
to your organization
and put it into use.
I wanna get you familiar
with the constructs
that you'll be using
under the hood to do that,
and I want you to understand
which you should use
and which scenarios and
how you might apply them
for your network's very specific needs.
To get started, we're gonna talk through
how we might set up Global
Resolver using the CLI.
If you're more interested
in the console flow,
we'll be going over that
too in just a little bit
as part of our demo.
The first thing that I
want to do when I want
to create my Global Resolver
is define the regional scope.
So as we mentioned, when you
make this create resolver call,
you're going to be passing
in at least two AWS regions
that are going to be used
to serve your DNS traffic.
Optionally, you can also
configure an observability region
where that observability
region will be used
to aggregate your logs such
that you can review them later
if you have compliance needs
or you'd like to do some investigation
about why DNS is working
the way that it is.
Once I've created my Global Resolver,
I'm going to be given
back a set of IP addresses
and a DNS name for my Global Resolver.
These are gonna be static for
the lifetime of your resolver,
regardless of what other
configuration you take,
and they'll be useful
when you start configuring your clients.
Following the creation
of my Global Resolver,
I can start to define my DNS views.
These DNS views are logical containers
for all of my configuration policies
and allow clients to
access my Global Resolver.
Now by default, the Global
Resolver has no access,
regardless of how I try to throw packets
at those IP addresses or that DNS name,
they're not going to work.
So the next thing that I
need to do is create a way
for my clients to become authenticated.
As Adhish mentioned, I
can do that in two ways.
I can use access sources
to take my known public IP
addresses for my clients
and configure them simply.
If I have roaming clients,
I might like to use access tokens
and instead create these
pre-shared kind of secret keys
that I'll then distribute
to my clients later on.
Now once I've created these,
my clients can then start
to use the individual views
that have been mapped to these
access tokens or sources,
and it's gonna be kind of vanilla DNS,
just a public DNS resolver.
But I might want to do more than that,
so optionally, I can also
start customizing these views.
I can create things like firewall rules.
An example that we have on
the screen here is something
that maybe your spouses or
your managers might like to do
to do while you're here at re:Invent.
I can block gambling
for all of my clients.
Additionally, I can associate
things like hosted zones
that allow me to customize DNS resolution
for my own internal
applications as I see fit.
I can continue to layer
these things on as needed
and update DNS views later
on as my policies change
or additional private hosted
zones become provisioned.
Now I've walked you through
how to create your Global Resolver.
I want to give you some best practices
for those key focus areas
that Adhish mentioned earlier.
So we're gonna talk through
some of the best practices
for achieving split-DNS resolution,
securing your global access,
improving your security,
and failover and multi-region resilience.
First, let's start with
achieving split-DNS resolution.
So as called out,
a single Global Resolver
can be responsible
for many, many views.
You can think of the Global Resolver
as just those IP addresses and
kind of the networking setup,
but how my clients
actually get a DNS answer
is a logical construct
held by those views.
Those views can take many different forms
and can be customized to fit your needs.
So I may have some networks
that are very open, right?
Clients that don't have
very many restrictions,
and I may have some clients
that are maybe highly-sensitive workloads
where I need to lock down
DNS and only allow them
to resolve a very small
set of domain names.
I can put both of those
into two different views
and associate them to a
single Global Resolver,
and then map the clients
through the sources
or tokens appropriately to those views.
How this might look under the hood?
So maybe I start with DNS
View A here on the left
and I might add in a
couple of hosted zones.
These can be the same private hosted zones
that you already have for
your VPCs or brand new ones.
I may also create a firewall rule,
and then layer in my access source
with the IPs as appropriate.
Now if I wanna spin up a new view,
maybe I have new resources
or maybe I wanna reuse some.
So you'll see in the example
here, I'm reusing this.
Top hosted zone has the same ID,
but every other resource below
it is a completely new one.
This allows us to quickly get
to consistent DNS resolution
without needing to provision
new networking infrastructure
where I want it,
but to specialize those views
where I want it as well.
Next up, let's talk about authentication.
At a high level, we have
those two same constructs.
We have access tokens and access
sources, but beneath those,
there are individual
kind of protocol supports
and some nuances that
I want to talk through.
When it comes to access tokens,
you can use first DNS over HTTPS or DoH.
When you're configuring
DoH on your clients,
you're going to be specifying
a very specific DoH URI or URL
that includes the access
token to be passed upstream
to Global Resolver.
One of the nice things
about this option is
that it's supported by
common operating system
like Windows and macOS today.
So you can go and configure those clients
without ever installing
a new client software
or having to do much
configuration on those.
Another option for access
tokens is DNS over TLS or DoT.
This is often supported by
common DNS server softwares
like Unbound, CoreDNS and others,
and is a really good option
if you have a centralized DNS forwarder
for an environment that your
clients are forwarding to first
before you want to egress
into Global Resolver.
For DoT, we will be
configuring that DoT client
to inject an EDNS0
option or a DNS extension
that specifies a very
specific DNS operation code
and your access token,
and can, again, pass it
upstream to Global Resolver.
On the access sources side,
we support all three of these protocols,
but in a bit of a simpler way.
You can choose to use DoH, DoT,
or the more vanilla Do53, UDP, TCP, DNS,
so long as you're willing to
configure those source IPs.
This is a really simple option
if you have fixed IP sites
where you've got that list
of IPS readily available
and you don't want to go
and configure client devices
in any way at all.
One important note here,
your DNS views can use multiple
access types as needed.
So in the example here,
you can see that View A
has both an access source
and an access token
configured at the same time,
and View B has only an access source.
That's absolutely okay,
you can mix and match these as needed.
Additionally, each view is meant to scale
to handle thousands of
potential tokens and sources.
So if you have many,
many roaming clients or many
sites that you wanna configure,
you can do that all behind one
view or many views as needed.
Next up, let's talk about
improving your DNS security.
Now because we've had DNS firewall,
the same service that's
used on your VPC DNS today,
we've seen a lot of learnings
from customers over time
in the ways that they
configure this service.
There's a lot of
configuration that you can do
and a lot of customization.
As Adhish mentioned earlier,
you can build exemptions
for your trusted domains,
enable those advanced protections.
We can support both
fail open and fail close
if you're more concerned with
availability or security,
and you can do both allow
and deny by default,
in case you wanna operate
in that walled garden mode
where perhaps you only
allow a very small set
of names to be resolved.
I want to talk through
how we've seen customers
adopt DNS filtering
and kind of the safe way to do it.
So first, one of the
things that we see many
of our customers do that we recommend is
to start with an allowlist
for your organization's
highly trusted domains.
These are the things that
you know should never,
ever, ever be blocked.
If you're going to be using
the advanced protections
that we have that are backed
by some very smart
machine learning models,
we still recommend that you
allowlist your trusted domains,
just in case you happen to be
doing anything that happens
to look like tunneling or DGA
traffic for those domains,
it'll still be allowed.
We often also see customers
who are willing to block
for our most high confidence thresholds
on those advanced protections,
but maybe they still
want to receive alerts
for the lower thresholds.
And so you'll see our
priority values here allow us
to do that, we can layer
in our high confidence,
and then below that put our low confidence
where maybe our security
teams are gonna be sifting
through our logs and
looking at those findings
rather than blocking
production traffic outright.
Now as customers adopt these features,
we see them work through
kind of a phased approach.
It often starts where
customers are starting
with log analysis on their DNS traffic.
They're looking for those
highly safe, trusted domains.
They're looking for things
that might be spurious,
and they're coming up
with what they think
might be reasonable rules.
We highly recommend the customers start
with alert rules where in phase two,
you go ahead and start building
out what may eventually become
your production rule set,
but you enable it only in an alert mode
where you can then go
back to your DNS logs
and see what would've been blocked
had you turned these things on.
For many customers, they
cycle back and forth
between kind of phase one of
log analysis and phase two
where they fine-tune
their policies over time
and they adjust them
until the number of alerts
that they're seeing
becomes very, very small,
and they're confident now
that they can move on to phase three.
In phase three, you take
a simple rule update
and you change your alert rules
into actual block rules,
and at this point,
your traffic starts to receive
those DNS filtering policies
and they become enforced.
We still recommend that customers continue
to monitor their metrics and their logs
to look out for a new, you know,
spike in blocks or kind
of new spurious traffic
that might be being
identified by the service.
Your workloads are going to change,
you're gonna take new dependencies
and update your software over time,
and there will be some
maintenance required there.
All right, that's all
I have on DNS security.
Finally, let's talk about failover
and multi-region resilience.
Global Resolver is designed
to offload the complexity
of multi-region DNS deployments.
The service works to protect your network
from both internet, routing
and service impairments,
and automatically redirect traffic
to maintain that high availability.
As called out, when you
provision your Global Resolver,
you get two IP addresses back.
Behind the scenes,
those two IPs are backed
by separate redundant capacity,
and we always recommend
that clients are configured
with both those IPs such
that should there be an issue
with one part, one of those IPs,
they can quickly retry and
distribute traffic to the other.
Now that's pretty standard in DNS
to have your primary and secondary.
Let's talk about how the
service works behind the scenes
to maintain availability
at an even higher standard.
When routing into regions
that you've configured
for your Global Resolver,
your traffic is first routed
through AWS edge locations
that are close to your client.
There's more than 400 of these
edge locations worldwide,
and that ensures that
they're always close by
to your clients regardless
of where they reside.
Now what happens if one
of those edge locations has a
network or service impairment?
Global Resolver's anycast
route announcements ensure
that we are able to quickly fail away
from an impaired edge location
and onto one that can
successfully process your traffic.
Now this same concept applies
when it comes to our
multi-region resilience story.
So should AWS,
in the rare case be having
an AWS service impairment
in a given region, that secondary region
that you've selected or if
you've selected more than two,
your clients will again be rerouted
to the next available region.
We think this provides
a really robust story
and helps automatically solve
for your disaster recovery
and multi-region resilience requirements
that you might have for your services.
All right, that's all I
have for best practices.
I now wanna talk about a case study
that we have covering
Just Walk Out stores.
As Adhish mentioned earlier,
Just Walk Out is a technology
that simplifies shopping
that's been delivered by Amazon
and helps customers get in
and out of stores quickly
where they can enter a store,
grab what they want off the shelf,
and get back to their day
without ever having to queue
or stop at a cashier.
You might have used one of these locations
at a sporting event, maybe at the airport,
or even here in the conference center
where our merch store over
in the Venetian has one
of these today.
The technology backing these
uses a combination of cameras,
RFID, sensor fusion
between those two things,
fast checkout registers
that scan your phone quickly for payment,
and all of those things
require a very robust network.
All of those network devices
need DNS to function.
Behind the scenes today,
Just Walk Out has a very large
distributed DNS footprint.
They have over 300 of these
stores across Australia,
Canada, Europe and the US,
and these result in over 550
million DNS requests per day.
To handle these, they
provision infrastructure
in four AWS regions.
Now pre-migration to Global Resolver,
their footprint looks something like this,
albeit a little bit simplified.
On the left-hand side of the screen,
you can see that they have
a centralized DNS forwarder
that's the first hop for all
of those cameras and servers
and processing devices.
Those DNS forwarders are then
sending into AWS regions,
there's four AWS regions
where they have a custom
DNS server software
that's doing a couple of things.
For one, it's doing the IP allowlisting.
They're sending this over plain Do53
and they're IP allowlisting each store
that they build out with that fixed IP.
They are applying some conditional,
both DNS zones where they
have per store DNS records
that they need to serve up
and conditional DNS filtering
rules where they have a front
of house and back of house network
that have different security requirements.
Once those rules have been applied,
they were then forwarding
into Route 53 Resolver inbound endpoints
to help them get their internet
DNS resolution as appropriate.
Now this is a robust DNS infrastructure,
but it had a few things
that they wanted to fix.
They wanted to be able to
stand up stores quickly,
and they wanna be able to do that
without knowing the fixed IP
that they're gonna be
using for those stores.
They also wanted to be able
to reduce the effort required
to maintain this.
You can imagine that
that DNS service software
requires developers to go
and patch and reconfigure.
All of that new IP data
has to get loaded in,
those conditional filtering rules have
to be updated over time.
So post-migration, we
see something like this.
Just Walk Out has instead
moved to using access tokens
where they can pre-provision
these access tokens way ahead
of store buildout and
assign them to stores
as they come online.
They're able to use
encrypted DNS to communicate
between those stores and Global Resolver
via their access token,
and that access token maps
them to store specific views
for both front of house
and back of house networks,
applying the policies automatically
with no DNS server software
requirement on their end.
This is able to deploy
to the same four regions
that Just Walk Out has today,
but should they choose to go to five
or more regions tomorrow,
they can do that at the flip
of a switch on Global Resolver,
getting lower latency for clients
close to those new regions
and additional failover.
They saw a lot of really great
migration benefits from this.
They got enhanced security
from the DNS encryption,
as we mentioned, a greatly
simplified network architecture,
support for those dynamic IP addresses
where they may not know
them ahead of time,
and a greatly reduced operational overhead
where they don't need to
maintain that server software.
Next up, I'd like to
walk you through a demo.
I'm gonna caveat that this is a live demo
and we just launched a couple
days ago, so bear with me.
Hopefully, we don't have
any problems with the wifi.
So for this demo,
I'm gonna be walking
through a Global Resolver
that I provisioned ahead of time
and showing you how this
works behind the scenes.
I've got some DNS commands
over on the right-hand side
of the screen that I'll be
using throughout the demo.
So you can see here our
Global Resolver console
where I've created this
demo-global-resolver.
It's currently backed by two regions,
one in us-east-1 and
the second in us-west-2.
Behind my Global Resolver,
I have two DNS views.
I have an open-access-view
and a restricted-access-view
that kind of configured the
way that you would expect
where our open view is able to query
and resolve kind of whatever,
and our restricted-access-view
has some restrictions
on top of it.
Now for our restricted-access-view,
let's talk about this one first.
I've enabled DNS firewall
rules to block two categories,
both travel and shopping.
I have one private hosted zone
that's doing some custom DNS resolution
for globalresolver.com that'll
show off in just a minute.
And I have two access sources configured,
no access tokens, but two access sources.
One of them is
for my very specific EC2 instance IP,
and the second one is for the IP range
that we're using here at re:Invent today.
So if you happen to be
sitting in the audience
and you have a laptop open,
you can try a DNS query like this today,
and it should go ahead
and get resolved for you.
Please feel free to try that out
as I'm talking if you would like.
I'll leave this here for just one second
if anybody wants to take a screenshot.
All right, fantastic.
Now I'm gonna be showing a DNS resolution
from two specific instances.
The first that I've
called IP-Demo-Instance
has this public IP you can see here,
which corresponds to
this same access source
that I've configured.
Let's go to that one first,
and I'm gonna have to
reload here real quick.
Cool, so for this EC2 instance,
I should be able to grab one
of my sample queries here.
And what you can see that I'm
doing here is a simple dig
or DNS lookup command towards the IPs
that were allocated for my
Global Resolver for amazonaws.com
and I'm quickly giving back those IPs.
Hooray!
I know you're all very excited
to see a standard DNS query.
Now I can also do some more cool things.
So let's go ahead
and use that private hosted zone
that I mentioned I configured earlier.
So here, I'm doing a lookup
for a TXT record called
view-name.globalresolver.com.
And you can see when I
do this, I get back...
I'll zoom in for you.
I get back a
restricted-access-view TXT record
so I can prove to you that
I'm using the right view.
Now because this is a
restricted access view,
I have some DNS policies
that I've applied.
So for example, we're all here
in the lovely Wynn
hotel here in Las Vegas,
but because I've
restricted access to travel
as a domain category, that hotel
domain is gonna be blocked.
I'll show you that here.
So as I looked up wynnlasvegas.com,
you can see that I got back this NXDOMAIN,
which is the response that I configured
when I configured my block rules.
Pretty cool stuff.
So next up, let's talk
about our open-access-view
and show off access tokens a little bit.
These are gonna be a little more advanced
because we have to
embed the right metadata
for the request to be resolved,
but we'll show you that here.
So no firewall rules on this view.
Similarly, I have yet
another private hosted zone,
no access sources, but one access token.
Now for this instance, and I'll reload.
For this instance, I have
already shared my access token
to this host and some
environment variables
and I'll show you those here.
You can use them while
they're active if you like,
if you're quick on the screen.
But here's my access tokens.
So I'm gonna ahead and source these,
and so that they're loaded in,
and let's do some more
fun DoH and DoT queries.
So to start,
I will do a DoH query for amazonaws.com.
I'm gonna use kdig
or the Knot version of dig,
which is a little bit more advanced
and lets me do things like
inject EDS0 and do DoH on demand.
And so you'll see that here,
And hooray, I'm able
to issue this DoH query
with the very specific,
as you can see here,
URL or URI that passes in
token equals my access token
that I configured,
and I'm able to get a response
back for amazonaws.com.
If I check kind of the same
thing for my view name,
you will see
that I'm now using the open-access-view,
which I configured in
a separate hosted zone
for that same DNS name.
I'm giving you that split-DNS resolution
between your two views.
The last thing I wanna
show is a DoT query,
which is again very similar,
but instead of +https,
it's using the +tls flag that you can see,
and it's adding this EDNS0 option.
65440 is our predefined access token
op code, and then the open access token
in string encoded format here
so that I can do my lookup
for amazonaws.com again
and get back my DNS resolution.
So there you have it, we
have a Global Resolver,
we've configured a couple of views,
and I've shown you how we
can use our client side bits
to go and configure those.
We do have good examples
in our documentation
of how you might configure your clients,
be that Windows or macOS
devices to do those DoH lookups,
if you're interested in
that kind of configuration.
I'd now like to hand it back to Adhish,
who's gonna talk through
some of our closing steps.
- Thanks. (faintly speaking)
- Yeah, thanks.
- Thanks, Matt. Hopefully,
there was a fun demo.
I don't know if you got to
try it, but once you're out,
you can definitely try it out
and let us know what do you think.
I'd like to also talk
about the next steps here.
What are the key regions that
we are available in today?
And also give you a
glimpse about the pricing.
During preview, we will be
available in 11 different regions
across North America, Europe,
Asia Pacific, and Australia.
You can try out the new
service in these regions
and let us know what you think.
In terms of pricing,
we'll be charging you based
on two key dimensions.
One is the number of
regions that you create
and two is the number of queries
or the query volume coming
from your clients.
We'll be charging you on a base rate
for the first two regions combined,
and then for every additional region,
there'll be an additional charge.
For query-based pricing, again,
for the first billion queries,
there'll be no charge.
Everything above 1 billion
is gonna be charged.
The good news is that
you'll not be charged
for price during preview,
so you are free to use this service
with no additional financial
constraints that you may have.
And with that, we have come
to the end of the session.
Hope you enjoyed it.
Do feel free to provide your
feedback through your app,
and hope you have a
great rest of re:Invent.
(coughs) Thank you.
(audience clapping)